hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to homecoming starring
markiplier now we just got chased by a
horrible monstrosity or someone that
turned into a horrible monstrosity we're
not sure which I don't need to go back
to my room it's easier to stay here okay
alright you stay around the bloody
toilets I'm sure they're fun and free
and fancy okay hello I used to be a
painter I mean I guess I still AM but I
haven't made anything in so long oh
that's kind of sad being robbed of your
skill I mean isn't the whole situation
that these people are kind of in limbo
they're stuck between life and death
and that's no good chica why are you
chasing your tail over that I'm sorry
chica she just caught my eye because
she's asserted chasing her tail randomly
she never really doesn't oh why I get
out of bed if there's nothing you care
to do I should just go back to sleep
oh and roll over she did man that sounds
like depression symptoms and that's no
good
I mean that would be odd if the people
that were stuck in this limbo it doesn't
make any difference nothing will change
anyway what's the point that really
sounds like depression is how why these
people are stuck here because they can't
I don't know they can't find the
motivation to move forward the reason I
watch the sunrise this morning I think
I'm almost ready to move up to floor 5
it seems better there oh ok so some sort
of like manual choice they have to do
like they have to choose to ascend in
this world oh it does seem better up
here oh this is lovely it's very warm
and golden I don't hate it here to be
honest don't you have a funky smile
there are a lot of things I miss but
then there are a lot I don't okay thanks
for being nice and vague I really wanted
a lot of description here and you didn't
deliver it all ok hello who are you
he looks so determined when he came
through do you think you'll succeed it's
possible right I don't know you're all
speaking so vaguely I have no idea
what's going on I'm not here because I'm
ok I'm not ok and I won't be I'm just
okay with never being ok now
that's a cryptic way of looking at life
and existence or nonexistence or
whatever else you want to call your time
here chicas going nuts over there well
someone wasn't very hungry
hello teddy bear again huh probably
lightens the mood I don't know I seem to
like all the blood downstairs things
could have gone another way but they
didn't there are no alternate endings in
life huh
that's fancy well there might be
alternate endings in this game I mean
honestly who knows are you the
gatekeeper I've totally accepted what I
am
I have nothing deluding me or holding me
back anymore isn't that great oh is it
people accepting their dough why don't
you become a monster too you can say
with the oh sorry don't bother trying to
escape I will bother immediately oh god
damn it I didn't aah you bet I'll try
again that's the first time that it's
given me a try again what am I supposed
to do help me help me oh jeez no it's
giving me a try again before but this
one happens happens to be very immediate
oh boy oh boy oh boy what do I do
it's not very clear not very clear oh
man that was quite the wicked haymaker
cuz I gotta get a rounding so that I can
get back in to the upstairs in the next
area but whoa
mark I sense that you're struggling let
me help the best way I can uh man that'd
be great
I'll show you the best path to take
you'll still have to travel it just
right to not be caught I know you can do
it
thing to escape what [ __ ] to escape
ducking to escape blocking to is okay Oh
Oh that is awfully handy thank you sweet
in here what oh oh I didn't know the
that was a thing you could do I mean I
was gonna figure it out but thanks for
the clue together with him take your
help and shove it up your butt hey boo
ha ha ha ha god damn it let in help at
all
what it No oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah
good thing I'm so fast can get a lot of
training in my love ha ha those do glows
no thank you
ok did I finally make it we make a save
II soothe all right I got my saved you
saw over here let's see what's going on
away hello ah good I know she's around
here somewhere
come out come out wherever you are
marki hello uh-oh uh-oh aren't you a
lingering spirit me no I'm alive like
you mi yeah I guess it makes sense that
you are the nice lady on the fifth floor
said it's hard for lingering spirits to
ascend in the hospital I thought you
might have been one of the bad ones and
you'd figured out how to get up here nah
I'm a friend I was sent by your nurse
actually nurse Hale my name is Mark Oh
new friends are nice but I've known her
for a long time she's my best friend I
think you're right about that she saved
your life by calling me here how come
well what are you wouldn't you what
we're doing right now is dangerous we
can only stay out of our bodies for a
while and then we can never go back oh I
know it must be boring in your body but
nurse Hale says they should be able to
wake you up soon she says that a lot
I know she's trying as hard as she can
though it just gets so boring maybe
staying here as a spirit forever
wouldn't be so bad you know on bat I've
just met a lot of people in that
situation and trust me they're not happy
will you stay and talk to me then just
for a little while of course let's go
ahead and move to your room though okay
okay
and then get back in your burdens jump
back and your friend Marty so tell me
about yourself Sophie uh well before the
coma it was just me and my dad he was
the nicest guy you'd ever meet he was a
brilliant doctor he was so good he
inspired people around them around him
to get into the health field - he was a
good cook - you'd make him delicious
dinners and every morning he'd make me a
different kind of sandwich he didn't run
out of ideas
oh no you just find recipe for some and
sometimes just make something up you
know always make an extra for Jenna - he
was very nice sounds like he took very
good care of you
yep and he will again when he gets back
where is he
it's kind of a long story well not like
I'm in a hurry to save Tim so how long
will I be asleep I don't know for sure
Bluebird I'll be as diligent and quick
as I can
well I have dreams huh I think you will
so I'll have nightmares too let's hope
not what can't I just go with you your
condition is going to get much worse
very soon the only way I can prevent it
is to put you to sleep for the time
being and then you'll wake me up and you
can make me all better
that's right I'm very close to being
able to cure you I just have to make a
trip to a far away place to use a
special machine okay don't worry it'll
all be over before you even realize it
promise it'll be like it never happened
something tells me that promise was not
kept are you ready yes sir I'm ready
very good screw being in a hospital
right now our time is done but I will be
the Sun aw I promise
did he put her to sleep write that in
there that's something we'd say whenever
daddy had to leave the Sun sets every
day but nowhere ever what happens it
will always come back I see and so
you're still waiting on him to come back
huh yeah I know it's been a long time
but it's not his fault he must have just
ended up needing more time to find the
cure well I hope he finds his way back
to you soon if he's not quick enough
nurse Hale might just have to might just
have you better before he gets here hmm
maybe she's a nicest lady I know but I
don't think the regular doctors can cure
me daddy said it was something really
advanced one way or another they're
gonna get you better until then you need
to stay put okay even when it's kind of
boring okay I will mark yeah will you
come back and see me sometime like this
again so we can talk to be honest I
don't have time not much time left as a
spirit a couple hours maybe but I'll
tell you what as soon as I take care of
a little issue back home I'll spend as
much of that time as I can with you okay
okay you have to be the son I will it
was nice to meet you you too well how
will I know exactly how much time I have
left I mean I'm all for visiting you but
I don't know if I have that much time to
go welcome back I must have been a
little crazy huh yeah it was a lot
sadder than I expected
scary you're dangerous I'm used to by
now but I feel bad for all the lingering
spirits don't worry too much about them
they've only recently passed time is the
best and the only medicine for them
they'll pull out of it also you may have
found yourself to be a little moody as
you ascended the overall atmosphere of
an area is determined by its residents
this this is Ken effect out things look
as well as alter the mood of others who
pass through did you notice a theme as
you made your way yeah it got brighter
as I went up anyway there's good news oh
yeah it worked
Sophie's vitals look so much better
right away I came down here knowing
you'd talk to her that's great she's
such a sweet kid we're gonna get her
better I won't rest a second until we do
thank you so much for your help I'm just
happy that I was able to honestly I'm a
little jealous I'm so fascinated with
all the spiritual stuff screw modern
medicine
get me into spirituality but I'm really
like I don't really get to experience it
like you do
oh well say what's the deal with
Sophie's dad she says he's away to
research or something yeah that was the
last she heard before she fell into a
coma he's been missing for as long as
she's been in a coma unfortunately he is
assumed to have passed is a shame too
he was a kind brilliant man he'd have
cured her I bet do you know what caused
the coma we're not exactly sure no we
figure it was most likely a side effect
of the stress caused by her condition
hmm uh yeah because it's not it's done
did by her dad well I guess I'm gonna
head home and take care of matters there
but I'll be back I actually promised to
spend more time with Sophie hey you're
very kind even though you're gonna get
trapped in the spirit world and your
body's gonna wither away and die oh well
if you know my my asking what is it that
you have to take care of back home I
feel that I owe you well I've got a
living weird creature of a box it's cute
and adorable but uh it talks and moves
on its own very strange it's being
chased by a body morphing shape-shifting
demon no not at all
you don't owe me a thing and I wouldn't
want to get you involved with it I would
if someone's offering help to defeat a
shape-shifting demon to rescue my little
biscuit I would sure as hell recruit
them it's the demon the same one that
kicked me out of my body the first time
he's got a fake body and is in my house
oh this is great it just does sound
great say what that's not the way I
would describe it I mean not the demon
but I can help you out after all believe
it or not we can banish the demons from
the safety of this creepy basement I'm
gonna raise up Maya my questioning
finger I'm gonna press X to doubt on
that one oh yeah and the time it would
take you to drive home I could teach you
to project your spirit to a remote
location you could summon your helpers
again oh you know the monsters you use
to get your body back the first time a
living spirit can do a lot of great
things if its wielder knows how
oh so it won't actually be here be there
I don't want to spend my remaining time
to be a wandering spirit your body would
be here but your spirit there would cost
some of your remaining time yes but I
can make it so you can speak with Sophie
from your body so that won't be an issue
other than people thinking you're
talking yours
how many superpowers do you have lady
this kind of sucks you know what's that
you're basically turning me into a super
owl hero but I can only use all these
powers for a couple hours yeah I guess
you're right yeah so are you ready okay
let's do it
yeah okay i i'm waggling the finger
adult pretty hard over here but let's do
it right and so once again nurse Hale
taught markiplier how to tame his
natural talent for supernatural
techniques it would attack the demon
from afar using his dreamt up allies
okay all right save game sure meet lovey
- save game oh hello who is you troops
we're made again did you let your body
get snatched again what an idiot
but step right here son of a [ __ ] I
don't want to hear right now Tim may be
in trouble so it's our mission the
corner that demon to destroy it once and
for all it was it's the third game
dinkus damn it we have to finish this
wave so why are you guys trying to fight
the deme what blood monster you're kind
of slow but you're all icky and bloody
that's got to be worth something right
what stabber I'm not sure I can trust
you but I don't have a choice you're
fast and deadly but you're the wild card
I'll have to use you carefully these
words I'm saying straight to your face
so you understand how about the threat I
think you is blind wolf you're a wolf
and you're blind you can see for crap
but you're decent hearing and a great
sense of smell off to make use of that
outside of the power I used to summon
you guys a comprar sealed door
and warp myself oh this is me oh I
didn't know that was me Oh
okay I will scare the demon away from my
room I will station you throughout the
house strategically to drive the demon
to the basement where I'll be waiting
any questions yeah what if good question
unfortunately we don't have time to okay
oh and away we go first of all which
room should I block off I should choose
the one that is potentially the most
problematic oh I don't know
block off I think the kitchen because
the Kreutz room the bathroom might also
be bad one the library you can loop
around
how about go at the bathroom yeah I
should blog blog this off now where
should I have the blind wolf hide
you
I should have put the butt stabber in
the bathroom
[ __ ] um
you
this Judy you
the library Queen blood arc station em
in this
to do okay I don't know how I'm not a
hundred percent sure how this is gonna
work
ah hello hi it me you again yep it me it
that boy
it means ghost boy how are you back in
that form I've learned a lot including
out to destroy you once and for all
you may as well give up now okay alright
bye then
good job given up ah oh
Kuki ha ha ha ha ha ha you've been by
stabbed oh ho you got stabbed in the boy
somehow I did this correctly yeah okay
so you done did been stabbed in the butt
alright so whoa oh
unfortunately his lack of thumbs proved
to be a bigger problem than his lack of
sight unable to climb the bookshelf to
the demon even if it could the initial
excitement of smelling blood dissolve
one didn't notice the skinwalker stink
in the air at the time the other side
was figured there was enough time left
to banish the demon sure okay so that
was wrong okay so ah okay so let's let's
do something else I'm gonna block off
the library because that seems that
seems to be a problem the blind wolf
should hide in the bathroom like right
away blood orcs should be in the studio
and then but stab her in the kitchen
because the kitchen bot stabbed and
worked quite well
I actually really like this by the way I
didn't mention that before this is a
really cool mechanic that I've never
seen in an RPG maker game that's really
awesome
okay let's see how this works come on
get him ARF
Roo oh it's blind of course it is all
right fine wait and we'll see how this
plays out we don't know how it's gonna
complete itself
look I gotcha okay stabbed in the butt
first so that's an important thing to be
stabbed in the butt first then maybe if
I have the butt stabber
yeah but the butt stabber wouldn't be
hiding would it maybe it would be the
butt stab her in the bathroom seems like
the good thing Hey and to slow RNAi
lauric notice the blood remind himself
he decided that the demon must have been
his long-lost brother oh it's a forehead
surely there's a better method okay I
think I got it I think I got it I think
I got it this time in the first game the
butt stabber was in the bathroom and I'm
pretty sure that's where I'd want me to
put him unless it's just throwing me for
a loop here Oh which one would a close
probably the library it seems that the
library's problem cuz then he would just
be able to run around all the time so
the library gets closed off
blind wolf in the kitchen the blood orc
in the studio and the bud stabber in the
bathroom and that should give me the
best opportunity to kill him dead if
that is in fact to my goal so I'm gonna
get him good watch this
alright so ah oh it's so secret huh it's
so cheap oh no wait
well you didn't stab him in the boy he
didn't stab him in the bud oh well
so Lebowski
okay so injured first which is good
question mark I'm not ever sent sure but
I'm gonna assume and then back to the
studio to be chased down to the basement
ah here we go
urgh huh blood arc nose blood did this
have been the long-lost brother no no
okay I know what the method is now now I
know what the method is now I know what
it is now I know what it must be cuz my
assumption was wrong I'm not trying to
kill him I'm just trying to chase him
into the basement
so the doggy go in the studio the blood
Orcas in the kitchen and in the bud
stabber in the bathroom and that means
that no one will actually be able to
hurt him
the blood orc will not be stupid get a
friend and then we'll be able to go down
to basement because apparently that's
where we want to chase him do all right
but stab or do your thing here all right
so he's there then the blood or should
do something different in the kitchen
than the wolf did
- slow that's the thing okay yeah how
not before being smeared with blood
first is that good does that mean oh
that means that the wolf is gonna be
able to smell the blood okay that's good
that's a good thing that means that
we're gonna be it's gonna smell the
blood notice this - send a blood in here
ah I got it I got it oh that's good
that's good that's good right there
that's good
okay yes beautiful demon was led to the
basement with nowhere else to turn mark
was waiting to finish the encounter you
bet it hello it's over oh well then this
again really I don't know how he knew
that was there I guess he was going for
the switch oh do I need to chase you why
couldn't you just give up cuz i'm marga
block wow i'm not i'm not fast ion come
back here
wait hang on oh yeah I am I need please
come back
oh I've got you cornered now deja vu huh
except last time this ended with you the
giving up of your own volition this time
you don't have a choice
where's Tim on the other side of this
wall my guess he jumped down maybe you
should go save him huh oh not just yet
not until I'm finished with you see
you've really learned how to get rid of
me then that's right it's been a fun
ride but this is where you get off and
not in the good way
well
haha do it then I don't have any tricks
up my sleeve I don't have anything oh I
don't have anything to fight back with
ha ha ha
putting on that sad voice really you're
gonna try sympathy after everything
we've been through
I'm sorry Sophie did you say Sophie no
no ok come on now don't know come on
come on
it doesn't matter do what you have to do
now because I met a Sophie not an hour
ago what are the not the same one you
didn't mean this Sophie today she's in a
coma
Oh
how do you know Sophie no how do you
know Sophie kind of a weird story but if
I hadn't met her I wouldn't know how to
send you away for good Zara makes sense
she probably hates me for what I did
what did you do to her do you go around
this town harassing everyone so this is
her father no I broke my promise I
failed
are you your Sophie's dad I don't know
what that I deserve that title but yes I
am her father is crazy what are the odds
that it was you pursuing me all this
time does she not send you to banish me
what no she's waiting for you she said
you put her into a coma she's just not
mad at me what was your plan tell me
yeah I'd like to hear this one ok I'm a
gifted doctor from Nicaragua I am uh I
was a single father a good father I
believe as fate would have it sophie was
diagnosed with an incurable illness but
I wasn't going to take incurable as an
answer so yes I induced a coma to
suspend the illness left to use a
friend's lab in another country with the
tech and resources that I needed it I
had a system in place to where the
authorities would be notified of
Sophie's whereabouts if something were
to happen to me walls way
something happened yes you can infer I
became a lingering spirit I refused the
next world because I wasn't finished in
this one I went through with my research
but it took much longer without a body
at the time I hadn't learned how to
commandeer one I had to get the things I
needed because I couldn't order them it
took me years but I did accomplish my
goal I found the cure I came back to
this town the town where Sophia was
hospitalized I visited her I don't think
she is aware that I was there
since then though her spirit has been
more active I could sense it I awakened
something in her and that drove me even
more to save her unfortunately also
drove me closer to becoming a malevolent
spirit every setback whittled away a bit
of my humanity if I even have that I
don't think any other spirit in the
hospital had reached the top level where
she stays since she'd been admitted
while I was there one of the spirits
taught me how to take a living body and
use it as my own Tommy what would happen
to my host you asked what the odds were
that's it's been me following you well
it's really not that far-fetched EnOcean
I watched big houses in town and waited
for a perfect subject to move in before
long there you were you had the money I
needed to order the supplies you had
excellent hand-eye coordination for the
surgery so I took your body while you
were weak you know the rest I suppose so
all those boxes out there are the
supplies you need to save her that's
what the stuff was for yes but it
doesn't matter now this body is too
twitchy I wouldn't go near with it you
almost trap me outside my body forever
you know what's not proud of how I've
been seeing myself II seven years older
just I became careless I'm sorry I am
sorry the funny thing is you've been
studying me all this time you've learned
my voice and mannerisms in history but
you didn't see my kindness I guess if
you just explained the situation to me
from the start I would have helped you
I just got reckless I shouldn't have I
wasn't thinking clearly and I still
don't trust you
I want to put that on record for all you
out trust this son of a [ __ ] as far as
I can throw him and I can probably throw
him not far she's a great kid isn't she
she seems very nice do you think how
much time do you have left to be outside
your body not enough maybe 20 minutes I
see but I know a girl who I believe
would be happy to participate in saving
Sophie really ah mark help the spirit
out of the hole as well as tiny box Tim
the spirit collected the supplies he
needed and headed to the hospital Mark
returned to his body and condors hail up
she informed him that giving her body to
the spirit voluntarily means that she
cannot take it back without permission
if he chose to he could keep her body
but she trusted him I do not I do not
she said if he was the same doctor she
knew all those years ago then she would
she knew he'd do the right thing
the surgery was prepped and nurse Hale
made sure there were no interruptions as
per the doctor's request she'd also
lured Sophie's spirit into a state of
sleep he knew it had become too
emotional to focus if Sophie were awake
and he didn't want her to remember this
way anyway nurse Hale gave her body to
him and the procedure began Sophie's
father worked diligently and
meticulously this was the fruition of a
plan he dreamt up seven years ago all of
his research paid off every step of the
way he knew exactly what to do he had
planned for every contingency he was
ready there was one thing he didn't know
how to handle however none of his tasks
or mental preparation could have readied
him for what happened as he finished up
the procedure his daughter's spirit
being an especially strong one pulled
itself back from unconsciousness what's
what are you doing Sophie you can hear
me I've been talking to you for so long
Sophie I I know this is strange but this
is Daddy I'm borrowing this body daddy
Hey
you're going to be all better now you
fixed me I knew you would and in that
moment Sophie's father had finally
resolved the situation that had cursed
him to be a lingering spirit in the
first place he had achieved true closure
you never gave up all this time of
course not you said you would be the son
so I knew you'd be back
in doing so he received an opportunity
that few lingering spirits achieve he
was given a second chance to move on but
he had to make up his mind right away
I'm sorry that it took me so long
Bluebird I'm so sorry don't be sorry it
doesn't matter all the matters is that
we're together and again now I I can't
stay with you I have to give this body
back and I don't have one anymore so I
can't stay what you can stay you have to
a caged my Bluebird once and left her
for far too long I won't have you
spending your time trying to reach me
waiting on me again I have to go now or
stay forever I don't know what's ahead
but I know it's not here
this is the perfect ending to my story
here no it's not fair
you have to take care of me you have to
make a new sandwich for me you owe me a
lot of them I've kept my final promise I
have to go now Bluebird fine our time is
for now is done but tell Jenna and mark
I will never forget them I know they'll
make sure you're cared for daddy I said
our time now is done you have to I love
you Sophie I love you more than anything
I have every second since I first held
you for every second I've been gone
I love you too please our time for now
is I will always love you Oh
in case you didn't get that that was
like he wouldn't say the other half of
that thing where he will always be the
son
Sophie recovered from her coma and her
condition was completely cured
she began physical therapy and improved
faster than expected there was no
denying that she was strong spirited her
father having found solace and finally
being able to keep his promise was
unbound to the physical world his spirit
was able to move on to whatever might
come next
nurse Hale woke up from her first
spiritual adventure and became the first
person to hear Sophie's voice truly hear
it in seven long years Marc planned a
party that would trump his original not
only because it would be bigger but
because it was a true celebration of
closure the demon was at peace well damn
that was much different than I expected
it to be I mean obviously it was you
know kind of similar in the other games
but it was just the story took a
different turn than I thought it would I
mean when I first heard that like oh the
demon was the father the whole time the
father that you introduced in this game
and only this game Oh Cassie but no that
really did that connected that did that
landed pretty well I mean it seemed like
it could have it could have gone a few
different ways but that landed pretty
darn well I'm pleasantly surprised by
that excited for five minutes 19 this
time it's super mega personal top of
them evening to you Lottie I'm having a
good time Aria Aria are you sure about
that
I brought Zooey's for the after but it's
Jen Tran Tran on the real oh okay well
he's got it ass outta this one
altogether huh and maybe it was for the
better
oh how cool is that we gotta prove it to
provide some foreshadowing in the second
game long before this whole plot was
starting to unravel I'm important I
don't remember that at all I trust this
weighed more yeah I seen that video
where you played Captain Falcon that's
how come you was able to Falcon punch me
in the canopy huh but for real you got
any okay
goodbye thanks Bobby
I appreciate it did I did real good I
don't know why you even invited me if
I'm not allowed to stab but what's even
is life without stab budding I promise
how to kidnap anyone at your little
party you're the only person who
actually paid me for my work even to
this day yeah Wow you're not really
intimidating in the proper light you
think I'm cute Oh God all right yeah
those are the developers up there hi
mark I guess now it'll be a lot easier
for us to visit each other with me being
in a real body Jenna says I can live
with her from now on and stay as long as
I want
she says you made this possible so thank
you so much well that's up the kind
nurse I'll have you know many of the
lingering spirits in the hospital were
inspired by Sophie's father it won't
happen overnight but in time they will
find peace your actions were a catalyst
for them I can never thank you enough
and this tiny box Tim you did it mark
you're my hero
okay thanks Tim that's it then medium
box Mike's still doesn't have much to
add to the conversation nice thanks
again for playing our game it really
means a lot to us you can just ignore
John whoring himself out to you but we
don't really cuz you know the starving
guard is saying anyway I'm gonna pet the
werecat now okay hello John here the guy
who typed the words you're reading right
now she's Geralyn in case you forgot if
you like the sound rack I wrote for this
game search for a unicorn hole on
Bandcamp and you can download it I even
did some real instrument remixes of some
songs they sound pretty rad if I do say
so and I totally just did does it sound
too commercial it I mean it's free
anyway thanks for playing maybe one day
we'll come up with a fresh idea for you
this idea was fantastic thank you so
much for making this game thank you so
much for making the music and thank you
so much for at putting an interesting
story in and I have to go back and check
to see what the reference in the second
game was to this one because I want to
know how Wayne could have possibly done
something that cool so thank you
everybody so much for watching I really
hope you enjoyed this embed sure if you
got another fan game that
want me to play let me know down in the
comments below and thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye